my name is self nuke and I'm the
director of the community nations forum
thank you all for coming tonight I know
we will have some people some night
science circles and bellows and Nieman
Journalism fellows who will likely be
showing up in a little while so don't be
distracted by them that's what the
reserved seats are for before we get
started we have a bunch of co-sponsors
to this event which is fantastic and
we'd like to thank all of them include
radius at MIT which if anyone is
interested in you should explore it's a
great program
I hear the climate colab Women and
Gender Studies at MIT the MIT Center for
global change science and the Nieman
Foundation for journalism at Harvard so
thanks to all of them for helping out
with this also if you are interested in
events like this there is a mailing list
right there if you put your email
address we will let you know about
future communications forms events that
means you will get somewhere between
five and six emails a year we do not
email you about other events all we will
do is let you know about communications
forum events so please sign up if you
are interested in these tonight is an
incredibly exciting night we're lucky to
have these three women here and going
from stage right are you stage right
no you're stage left you're right stage
left we have Lisa song on the end she is
an alumna of MIT science writing program
an investigative reporter at Pro Publica
who covers environment energy in climate
change
Lisa joined Pro Publica in 2017 after
six years at inside climate news where
she covered climate science and
environmental health she was part of the
reporting team that revealed exons shift
from conducting global warming research
to supporting climate denial
a series it was a finalist for the 2016
Pulitzer Prize for public service even
though she did not win that do not feel
bad for her because in 2013 and 2014 she
reported extensively on air pollution
from Texas's oil and gas boom as part of
collaboration between several newsrooms
and she's the co-author of the Dilbert
disaster which did win a Pulitzer Prize
for national reporting congratulations
she beat out another MIT science writing
alumna here
Kendra PR Lewis is another alum of the
MIT graduate program in science writing
and she's the author of the book green
washed why we can't buy our way to a
green planet and covers climate for the
New York Times previously she's been a
staff writer for popular science where
she wrote about science the environment
and her hatred of mayonnaise her writing
has also appeared in 538 the Washington
Post Newsweek modern farmer and slate
and next to me is Beth Daly who I just
found out is also a neighbor of mine
that's the most pertinent thing she is
editor and general manager of the
conversation and has covered the
environment science and education for
almost two decades at the Boston Globe
she's also been an investigative
reporter at the New England Center for
Investigative Reporting and head of
strategic development for inside climate
news before joining the conversation she
was a finalist for the Pulitzer Prize
and has won awards from the association
of healthcare journalists and the
Society of American business editors and
writers before I turn it over to them at
the end of of their part of the
conversation we will have a Q&A please
come up to one of the two mics even if
we can hear you if you speak from your
seat this is also being recorded and
there's webcast and those people will
not be able to hear you if you're not
picked up by the mic and also please
introduce yourself in whatever it sent
you feel comfortable because we do
provide write-ups for these and so then
we can say instead of man we can say
John from wherever so without further
ado
I'll let them take it away wait wait
thanks so much Jeff um so this is great
great they have such a good crowd and
I'm such a really important topic not
mayonnaise but so I just thought it
would be really helpful maybe based on
with you Lee said just it just to talk a
little bit about your job and your beat
and and and some things you've covered
in them all go to Kendra and we'll go on
to the questions which I have a long
list a conversation yeah so I work in
the Pro Publica office in New York which
is our main headquarters and my job
basically is to write about climate
change and or environment and I have
basically complete freedom to pursue
whatever stories I want which is an
incredible luxury and amazing and very
few newsrooms where reporters can do
that and our specialty is investigative
reporting so we are often take weeks or
months or sometimes more than a year to
report and research and write a single
story or single series so we're able to
dig really deeply I think the the sort
of driving principle behind all of our
stories is we want stories that can
create impact so trying to reveal
wrongdoings corruption things that are
not great and then hopefully you know if
all goes well perhaps somebody with
power can change a law or change a
regulation or create a new regulation or
do something to fix the problem we're
revealing so our newsroom covers kind of
every beat Under the Sun so we have
political reporters and people who cover
immigration health care the economy you
know education and then there's a few
climate and environment reporters so
that's kind of power structured so I'm a
reporter on the climate desk so The
Times has a dedicated desk for a climate
reporting we're about two-thirds of us
are in New York about a third of a
certain DC the DC people do more
political and policy stuff in New York
we do our I do mostly science
I'm not on the sciences we have a
science desk but that is they're not
even on the same floor as us and so it's
a mixture of like daily reporting
stories so if a study is coming out and
then to make sure of those kinds of
stories as well as doing longer reform
stuff that can take you know weeks or
months to report out while I'm doing
sort of daily stories yeah and so it
really depends and then there's like
stuff like I call it the natural like
Hazzard beeps oh I'm hurricanes
wildfires things that have a climate
link I really like winter at least in
the north are in the northern hemisphere
because they're a few of those stories
that sneak up on you
yeah so that's great
yeah I you know I have a million
questions about everything about your
audience and how we talk about climate
change with journalists but I think it's
been really good to talk about some of
your stories first and and least I'll
start with you because you've done
amazing work on carbon offsets and it
was I don't how many people have read it
here but it was an amazing a lot of
people that amazing piece of journalism
that that really examining from several
vantage points now you sort of tell the
story how you got into it you know
something that I think intuitively is
people in some environmental spaces know
it was probably not working was this
idea you could offset carbon emissions
with trees and whatnot and but we've
actually set out to prove it
quantitatively in many ways by living it
more than two decades it's so yeah so
I'd look Tiki I think people want to
hear how you got into that story and the
challenges of it and sure how did I get
into it um so the end of every count we
tend to do projects on a calendar year
schedule so the end of 2018 I was free
from my previous stories and kind of
searching for a new story for the 2019
year and that was when the UN climate
negotiations were happening in Poland
and I started reading stories about you
know arguments with the negotiations
were
- this old un offsets program and this
was this program had been created
decades ago and the idea was you know a
company in a developed country could pay
someone in the developing world you know
often India China Brazil to build a
hydro dam or build a solar power plant
or something something clean and if they
could claim that this new project was
built in place of a coal power plant or
something that he made it more carbon
then they would take the difference of
the carbon emissions and then say
because you've built this cleaner thing
the polluter in North America or Europe
could then emit that many tons of co2
and it would be canceled out by this
project elsewhere and what was becoming
clear you know more than a decade after
the project's launched was tons of fraud
tons of problems with verifying that the
emissions reductions were real there had
been this report that came out saying
something like 85% of the emissions
reductions were very suspicious and so
this had been the biggest experiment
with carbon offsets never thought the
world had done and it was basically a
complete failure so that was kind of the
context of these and even that program
had decided there was one type of offset
which is somebody owns part of a forest
somewhere and they were gonna cut it
down but instead they're not gonna cut
it down
because you were gonna pay them for the
carbon offsets of what those trees are
worth and they're gonna use that money
to make a living in some other way that
doesn't involve logging and cutting down
the trees so this type of it's called
like a forest preservation offset and
even that old UN program had said these
types of offsets
are really difficult to quantify and
verify and so we're not going to allow
you to use these but there had been you
know in the past ten years this renewed
push to try and start these programs for
real on a large scale and the state of
California was debating whether to vote
on this measure that would encourage
these types of offsets so I'd seen a lot
of or
among activists and environmentalists
and there was a lot of vaguely worded
language like oh we know this doesn't
work you know we have examples of sort
of trial runs where we know this doesn't
work but nobody was saying anything
specific so I started trying to report
it you know as much as I could reading
old reports talking to the few
scientists who've actually tried to
study this in a quantitative way and it
became obvious that California was
basing a lot of its decision on what was
happening in this remote area of Brazil
the state called RA where they
supposedly had the world's best program
that was almost ready to do these kinds
of offsets so you know and and I it
became clear I had to go to Brazil but
I've never done international reporting
I didn't speak any Portuguese but my
newsroom completely supported me they
you know gave me the resources to we
hired a freelance reporter from Brazil
who was working in the US and she became
my co reporter we went to Brazil
together for two weeks talked to a ton
of people and we interviewed government
officials who blatantly said you know we
need the money from these offsets for
forest preservation to keep the trees
standing we care more about the
conservation money then about the
quantitative truth of the offsets
generated you know and and they were
very blunt about that and you know when
you talk to them and you see how bad
deforestation is it's completely
understandable they want they have so
little money to you know track illegal
loggers and miners they need anything
they can get to keep the tree standing
and so they're sort of making a bet that
it's more important to keep some trees
standing than to maybe have some
suspicious carbon offsets and that kind
of became a big part of the story is
some of the people involved kind of know
there's a lot of uncertainty and and
they're willing to acknowledge that but
it becomes for them a value judgement
about is it more important to keep the
amazon standing and healthy than it is
to maybe emit more co2 than we are
admitting on paper and so but there was
a whole lot of
problems with these types of projects
and we found one project in Cambodia
that had actually passed sort of the
most rigorous standards out there which
are run by a variety of nonprofits and
we partnered with a satellite non-profit
firm that actually found through
satellite analysis more than half the
trees and the project had already been
cut down ten years after the project
began yet it was still on the market and
selling offsets and the way you know the
way that these programs are run they
rely on people to go into the field
every few years and file a report but
they those people hadn't filed a report
in five years and they wouldn't actually
cancel the project for another ten years
at least beyond that so we were able to
tell them before their actual employees
that you know you might want to take a
look something is very wrong on the did
and what did I'm curious if California
was or did they after the story came out
you know they eventually voted to
approve the thing to encourage these
offsets you know but it passed by one
vote so I don't know maybe it would have
passed by more votes without the story
but I do know a lot of people you know
in the the state government did read the
story was discussed during the final
debates before the vote
you know there's in general one thing I
found is there's not a lot of
researchers or reporters looking
intensely at carbon offsets you know
they always come from a place of good
intentions and I think there can be some
reluctance to to probe that and there's
a lot of environmental groups who truly
support carbon offsets and you know have
invested a lot of time and energy into
them that's great I want to come back to
sort of like as you write these climate
stories how much you think about what's
happening after the fact and impact but
well I'd love to talk to Kendra about
you do many many stories stories but I I
really liked your wildfire story
written sort of that word taking place
all around the world is a wildfires and
I think can you talk a little bit about
how you concede that story and some
challenges to it and yeah so that was
one that was designed here sort of like
the Amazon was burning and I think I
don't think California has done fire yet
but people were sort of it were still
kind of recovering from last year
and they were kind of like you know
there's and there I think the footage of
like there were film but like satellite
images of like parts of sub-saharan
Africa that were on fire and it was a
lot of tweets about it and people seemed
very concerned about the Amazon and they
were kind of like can we you a piece
about how the whole like the world is on
fire and I was like well we can't
because actually worldwide wildfires
you're declining because of agriculture
actually so lots of places that should
be burning naturally are not burning
because we've chopped everything down
and planted crops so yeah I guess but I
said what we can say is these four
things we can say and I'll tell you them
on that man zip dropping and we can say
that the Amazon it's on fire because it
was deliberately set and they're linked
to climate change it's not climate
change didn't start those fires but that
obviously by burning the way that I
Mazzone that's burning it is
contributing to climate change and
that's not great we can talk about fires
like the ones that are happening at West
which are part of the natural ecosystem
but climate change is exacerbating this
wildfire cycle in conjunction with some
other factors and we can talk about
prescribed burns which cool burn or like
less intensive burns which are
deliberately set because lots of
ecosystems especially across North
America we're like I don't say evolved
with fire but that's kind of the best
way of saying it and so the United
States government
pretty much for over 100 years engaged
in this policy of higher suppression
that and it's also making wildfires
worse and then I came out with the
fourth one was I mean oh no the fourth
one was prescribed burn and that one got
dropped because it didn't quite fit into
the narrative that we were looking for
and the third one was I'm linking I'm
sorry but basically it was sort of like
sketching out do you remember I'm just
thinking now say this
today again but it was sort of like this
three bullet point there did and that
was just to help people kind of
understand fire my low keeping obsessed
with wildfires for a couple of years
which is I think why they were like can
you write this that's opposed to another
science reporter and one of the things
is that I have tremendous respect for
wildfire but also I think one of the
things that's really harmful with the
narrative and the way we talk about
wildfire is many people think that all
fires are bad and so the the hope the
point and that narrative was not to say
that it was great that the Amazon was on
fire it was not great but to say that
like this is why it's not created to
really kind of under had that
understanding that like fire is highly
context dependent whether or not it is a
good fire or a bad fire and yeah and so
that was fun I guess it was really
interesting I ran into a fire researcher
that I sometimes use but didn't use for
this story
shortly after and he was like it was one
of the best stories on wildfire he'd
read about the whole situation and I was
really grateful because I was the other
thing was it was true that sub-saharan
Africa was very much on fire but at the
time the area that was on fire there's
concern now about the Congo like the
rainforest in the Congo and that's a
different category but it was a savanna
and that was on fire and that tends to
burn kind of dramatically every year
because I'm there's like human start
fires but also lightning concert' fires
and these tend to get started by
lightning and so though it's always also
it was combination of those kinds of
fires and AGG fires and so helping
people kind of understand that nuance is
really important because as we move into
a warming world there going to be more
of these kinds of discussions happening
the story struck me is incredibly well
well reported of course but also both of
them are so well explained it felt it
was very clear like you walked away
saying oh I get it
and I wonder when you pursue these
stories how much are you thinking about
your audience and who is your audience
and you can speak both from from your
organizational standpoint but also
personally because sometimes it can be
very different you know um I think it's
a little bit different for me then I'm
cuz I'm just doing so many mysteries and
lisas doing and so in general I assume
but as people don't want to read a
climate change story
even if they accept the sightings and
are relatively engaged when you click on
a link about climate change you're
generally not expecting having these so
I kind of go into every story was kind
of that in mind and also the idea that
people are smart but uninformed which i
think is useful so I try and like
describe all the terms I try and kind of
really explain it to people in ways that
are easy for them to wrap their heads
around because I live in you know like
that that story about that you liked
that came that was a day and a half's
worth of work basically I'm they walked
it on Monday and they wanted it and I
much longer but the the background of
that is I had been obsessed with my
advice for two years so that was just
like me being like well I know all of
this stuff and like I know all the
people like all of the people to call
and like see like behind that like day
and a half of work was like two years of
like reading and studying and like being
obsessed with wildfires and going out on
a prescribed burn and it like so who's
someone's reading that story like who's
on the other side like who you imagining
or who do you hope is reading it and um
you know someone who lives in California
someone who's freaking out about the
Amazon I'm somebody who is thinking
about parking a hot car on grass turns
out but basically like any you know I'm
very fortunate to work an amazing art
director on our team and so I am very
lucky to have a lot of evocative imagery
and those in graphics and those sorts of
things to kind of entice people in when
the study is kind of heavy but yeah
generally I'm you know I don't have like
this specific person in mind beyond
maybe like slightly curious I guess yeah
yeah a little bit more but at least I
want to explain it is different yeah I
think it's slightly different you know
we are writing for a general audience we
assume that our audience knows what
climate change is and maybe is at least
slightly worried about it but beyond
that we don't expect them to know any of
the jargon or terminology so we are
writing not for a climate walks or we
want them to read it as well but they're
gonna read it anyway cuz it's probably
part of their job but we really want the
general audience who
and you know and like Kendra said really
hard to get people to read climate
stories for fun because often they're
not fun it's sort of doom and gloom beat
is what we call it and for this one I
think because it was so counterintuitive
the idea that you know everyone has a
warm and fuzzy feeling when you talk
about saving trees and particularly
saving the Amazon and you know you want
to pay money to rural communities so
they can find a more sustainable
livelihood and then in return they save
those trees and you cancel out your
carbon emissions from when you're
driving or from this particular company
that sounds great
poking holes in that can sometimes feel
not great but I think there was enough
curiosity about what it actually means
to look deeply into it that we hoped
people would respond and we did get a
lot of readers the other obviously
people we want to read are people
because we were writing about something
as California was about to make this
important decision we obviously wanted
all of the board members and the
regulators and anyone involved in that
decision to read it so they could be
better informed we wanted residents in
California who cared about the Amazon
and cared about this decision to read it
and so you know when I die I know
because I was told by residents in
California that it was read by a lot of
people within the state and people
involved in this decision so that that's
always a good thing yeah I mean I have
to wonder when you're when you're when
you're it I guess I did it too and I was
writing a story alright it is about the
also it's about the the language that we
use if you and I'd love you to address
that because maybe if you was a few
months back in September the Guardian
and several others have decided to call
I think one the gardens are the climate
emergency they were gonna call climate
change sir it's a climate emergency and
there were several other efforts to sort
of get journalists together and
journalism organizations together to
write about climate in a certain way
using certain language a sense of
urgency and it is quite controversial
among among journalism organizations and
journalists individually I just love for
you guys to talk about that like how
much does choosing the right language or
I guess what language do you use in in
and and what what's allowed in your
organization and if you think that's
helping what's gonna be a long question
but but I really what I really want to
get at is this idea of middle ground
write it like this this idea of if if a
journalist role and I'm not saying
everyone accepts that is to help conform
short of the general population on both
sides are you choosing language to try
to get at that are you saying no it's
it's an urgent issue we're gonna only
write about it like that to exclusion
some people I know that was that clear
but yeah I I don't think that we have
institutional rules on this it really
comes down to the story I I tend to just
use the term climate change because it's
accurate and everyone knows what it is
and you're not distracting them
sometimes they'll also use global
warming to avoid repetition perhaps in a
paragraph I think I used the word
climate crisis and a recent story I
wrote about cap and trade in California
but I believe it was in the context of
explaining that we're now in an era
where even in the past year or two the
public understanding and feeling of
urgency over the climate crisis has
expanded tremendously and so I thought I
think it was either a sentence like that
or something about you know we are now
at a point where people realize how
quickly and how drastically we need to
act and so it was in that context that I
think I use the term crisis but I don't
think I even talked about it actively
with my editor it just made sense given
what I was writing about and it felt
like the right
but I don't think we have blanket rules
on what terms to use so I work in a very
large institution we have the style
guide it is long and very detailed and
sometimes they're they're funny words I
can't think of one right now that I'd
written something and my editor changed
it and there's like why and he like
pointed to the style guide and it
doesn't like that structure of phrase or
something and I was like okay it was
like walking up and our CMS tells you
that it doesn't like certain words which
is fun so we don't use climate crisis
and I don't have like that just our role
and that's it I think in terms of
conveying so I did a story recently that
a lot of people did about like how
climate change is going to make future
generations sick and it's a really sad
and kind of troubling scenario like what
happens to kids who live in a 40 degree
Celsius world if we because that's kind
of the trajectory were on and so I had
these experts say very things about what
that actually means but um a friend of
mine read it and she said it made her
cry and another friend read it and it
made her cry and and I was like but it
was surprising to me because it was a
study story it was it based on a Lancet
report that had come out so I knew it
wasn't the only person here he'd covered
it and so I read um after the fact other
people's reporting and and I noticed
that what I'd done differently and it
wasn't deliberate I don't think was that
I didn't actually talk that much about I
talked about the impacts but I didn't
talk about the impact in a very
scientific way so like one of the facts
of a warming world is there's gonna be
more small particulate pollution in the
air and it's there partly because we're
burning fossil fuels and that creates in
and partly because as a good fodder
forest burn and that hates it so it's
like this double whammy and I talked to
this researcher and there was like you
know why is it that kids are more
susceptible than we are and she was like
their hearts beat faster and they're
long and their luck they breathe more
quickly and I remember that's like I'm
ruining it the quote was much better but
the the turn of fries anyone who's ever
held a child you can almost immediately
kind of feel it
which is why I felt it was important
which is why I put it in the piece and I
think that those sorts of choices are
what people felt like there's a guy a
developer who sits not next to me but we
hang out and in one of the open spaces a
lot and he's a developer so he's not a
reporter and he turned to me was like I
I read your articles like well I skimmed
it and it's like there and he was like I
just had a kid it kind of bummed me out
and like I was like both like oh I'm
sorry but also that was like good like
like you you you were the person who
should be bummed out because you had a
kid so like and you are your kid can't
do anything about this but like you can
so sorry I don't know where I'm going
with that but apparently and like it
resonated with a lot of people and it
was mostly because I made the decision
to use really evocative language and to
really tie it concretely to children and
so that another fact is out there you're
gonna have more they're gonna overheat
more and part of those and they overheat
more is because you go outside more and
like everyone remembers playing outside
as a kid and I had listened to the youth
climate marches which are happening and
so I made a decision to sort of one of
the speaker's had talked about how like
this is all happening on the backdrop of
the youth climate marches and so I like
and she's like kids today are actually
wondering whether or not they should
have children and I remember that one of
the protesters had said something in her
or one of the activists that have been
purchasing Jamie Margolin I think I'd
give him congressional testimony earlier
this year it was her Gretta and two
people I'm linking on right now and
she'd said something about how like
everyone who will come up with her after
the talk I'm telling her she's such a
bright future in front of her was lying
to their face to her face because it she
was committed to a planet that was dying
and I'm getting foreclosed so when I saw
it the first time I had a gut punch and
it just felt like a good quote and the
piece um and so I did because I'm
probably the only person here watch the
congressional hearing and so I don't
know how many people actually heard her
say it
just cuz apart from the current
impeachment proceedings commercial
hearings are not generally must-see TV
and so I think I think you don't always
like a
the problem with phrases like climate
crisis or climate emergency is that you
run the risk of them just becoming
another thing people say you know we
have the war on terrorism we have the
war on cancer we have all of these
languages but like we haven't actually
solved those problems and so I think
naming things appropriately matters but
I think it can become too easy that the
words are sort of decoupled from the
problem and so I think it can also
become a crutch and so in some ways our
decision not to use it means that I have
to work harder to convey the scale of
the problem and I think that is a good
thing because the problem is really big
and so I need people to kind of get a
gut punch when they're reading about
that scale it's so you know it's show
don't don't tell a preacher or what not
but so but still on that same subject
I'm curious oh well every climate
stories are a bummer right and sometimes
we don't click on them it's hard being a
journalist covering it I know so how do
you how do you do it right how do you do
it because a goal of a journalist is it
gets them to be the story right so if
you're kind of up against something
which we all know it's pervasive right
now in societies that people like I
don't even want to you know look at the
news this that everything so how do you
how do you approach stories trying to
get people into them to read them
because that's your goal I mean I think
it's it's just find find a story I think
that's relatable you know and that's why
we went after the offset story so much
with with going to Brazil the
combination of the great art direction
we hired a local photographer who knows
that part of Brazil really well and he
his English was also really good and he
took these amazing photos that we used
throughout the story we also hired an
illustrator to draw some illustrations
for it was just a really compelling
story visually and we hope that would
draw some readers in but also again
offsets are something that I think a lot
of people can understand and perhaps
many people have personally bought
offsets you know we
you take a plane flight oftentimes at
the end there's a button you can click
and you pay $5 and you offset your
emissions and you feel great about
yourself there's just not a lot of
transparency about exactly what projects
you're funding and certainly holes and
how the monitoring process for those
projects are going as we showed through
our reporting so I I definitely got a
lot of feedback from readers who said
you know hey I bought carbon offsets a
while back now I'm wondering if they
actually worked or I'm wondering how
well they worked you know what I maybe
five or seven years ago I remember
buying some offsets myself shortly after
the UN I think started a portal where
you could easily buy offsets and I
bought it a few times and didn't think
much about it and moved on and in the
course of reporting this story I flew
all the way to Brazil first to Sao Paulo
and then all the way west to the extreme
western part of Brazil then flew to a
city in the middle and then back to Sao
Paulo and and I flew so many miles and
then I got back and thought I don't know
what offsets I can buy because I don't
know if I can trust anything because I
had reported on the story on how
untrustworthy many of them are so I was
stuck in a position thinking I can't
even make myself feel better about the
carbon footprint that I spewed while
reporting this and you know I don't I
don't have a good solution for that I
would perhaps like to write a story
maybe to find the best offset projects
out there because there are good ones
they just may not be involving these
tree projects in the same way but
there's a whole world of many other
offset type projects out there that I
haven't looked deeply into I know it was
like really good and it was you and I
think you have because you're doing
these long like you have more freedom to
try to find things that I think that
people feel like they can actually stop
help solve a little bit and I'd love you
to talk a little bit about that because
it feels that feels
so that what we've this feature in our
newsletter called like one thing you can
do and it's his tension right because we
recognize the limits of individual
actions and so we don't want to give
people a bunch of like I don't know um
you don't need just raw advice that we
know doesn't actually shift the actual
impact but at the same time people want
to do something and so sometimes the one
thing you can do is literally like thing
like you know wash your clothes on cold
and sometimes the one thing you can do
is um when I think we said it was like
go to your community board meetings and
go to your planning board meetings and
like actually get engaged and where
things are getting cited in your
community and are you citing things and
flood zones are you guys going to be on
the hook for a tremendous amount of
money like in the future but one of the
things that we were constantly getting a
lot of like emails about was like well
what about clothes what about
sustainable fashion the footprint of
fashion is so big and the problem with
fashion is that a lot of companies are
saying that they're doing great things
but once you start talking to the
experts about like who's actually like
what how much transparency is actually
behind what they're doing it gets really
like fuzzy and basically the only name
company name that comes up repeatedly
over and over again is Patagonia and
even by Patagonia so and measured
they're like not doing enough and I'm
not being critical of them but they are
wrecked they they themselves recognize
the limits of what they've accomplished
and also you can't live in Patagonia
everywhere I don't think they make suits
yet but itself offers some women's and
and then there were these companies like
a lot of the fast fashion companies are
doing things like offering up 100%
organic cotton t-shirts and that makes
you feel good because you're not using
pesticides but cotton t-shirt Oriana
cotton often uses more water and it's
often grown in very thirsty places so
you're actually trading off to very like
I don't know how you do that accounting
but the one thing that we know is that
if you buy something and it lasts a long
time
you've already reduced your footprint so
the one thing you can do is buy less
clothes but if you're sort of under the
age of 40 or 45 you've probably not
grown up in an era where clothes
actually lasts so like how do you buy
clothes that last if you don't know what
to look for and so that was sort of the
genesis of this piece which is how do
you find clothes that last and it really
resonated with
readers and we like I'd mentioned me an
art director so we actually hired a
fashion photographer to go out and like
future lies I what I really wanted to
crash your photo shoot but I didn't -
like visualize all of the like the tips
and it was like really beautifully an
artfully shot and we put it in a little
Easter egg which was like a fake
Instagram account so if you like found
it and we did like some of the clips on
Instagram so that would you know because
there a lot of influencers and then
there were other things that I did that
I didn't even I did kind of consciously
which is often um so there is this like
slow fashion movement and there are some
really kind of famous names within that
movement like so Olivia Firth who's
Colin Firth wife has like is a big
purveyor of silicon but I kind of made a
conscious decision not to use some of
the biggest names in slow fashion
I actually went the opposite route and I
found like women of color who often
don't get enough recognition and within
the influencer he's been and I spend way
too much time with Internet and I am i
found a PhD student in the UK who's
running a slow fashion project and I
chose to highlight them instead and um
you know she emailed me and she was like
we had I don't remember the number but
like you know like the amount of traffic
she'd like normally gets in a year I got
her in a week which was like just like a
nice aside and and like somebody tagged
me and won it and then somebody tagged
the influencer and let her know that she
was mentioned in my story I didn't I
didn't think to tell her not because it
wasn't a bad start like it was you think
you think to warn people when you're
writing something terrible about them
but when you're having something nice
about them
you don't think about and they didn't
and she would like was like so shocked
and so pleased and so it was just like
this I don't this added benefit that I
didn't think about what like I didn't I
didn't think I don't this is done but I
didn't think how nice it is to be in the
New York Times when you're from a group
that isn't often represented in The
Times so that was really nice I don't
know why it's do that in there but it
was really it was it's a story that you
can actually you know people really want
to feel a sense of solution and and that
felt like you to do something yeah and
it was and and the other reason it sorry
other reason we went that route
we didn't want to tell people like if
you we didn't want to be liked by this
brand and the brand is very expensive
and so if you're going to a surf shop
the tips still work if you're going to
like I know the fanciest department
store the tips still work if even if
you're going too fast fashion retailer
the tips work and so that was the other
reason we kind of decided to go in that
direction it's great
the I don't want to monopolize all the
time but I do want to talk about
something that's really important that
that it is someone who's not writing
right now but I struggled with it and I
think a lot of journalists struggle with
it and it's it's it's environmental
justice because it's so it's so
incredibly important but I'll tell you
sort of like I talked to some I kind of
did a survey some journalist friends of
mine in the environmental field and I
know and and and most of them were
Boulder they're like my age you know and
fifties and they said it's really hard
to write about because it's super
important but sometimes the stories can
feel familiar and and I don't know if
you feel that way or not but so that's
the first question if you feel that way
and secondly if you whether or not how
do you how do you write about
environmental justice so it's part of
this this climate beat and so it's sort
of woven into it in a way that or do you
just hit it straight on every single
time and is that as effective so I think
that um oftentimes environmental justice
may be sort of one step removed from the
central thing you're writing about it if
it's a pure climate story but other
times it fits in really well and when it
does you definitely need to tell that
and and I think I didn't think about the
brazils story as a climate justice story
or environmental justice but there is an
element in there of it right and part of
the part of the reason why offsets are a
lot of people support offsets is this
idea that the global North you know has
profited and gained so many riches and
privileges from the ability to emit
carbon dioxide unchecked and that though
the countries that have more poverty and
are in the global south we are now
saying you can't emit co2 and not enjoy
you know we're not allowing you to enjoy
the cheap fast route to get richer and
that's just you know not right and so
perhaps if we can move some money from
the global north to the global self to
help them protect trees and at the same
time you know alleviate some of our
guilt and emitting then everything will
be perfect and work out but of course
that's not that doesn't work and so what
our story was saying is the the best way
to do that is just for the global north
to be generous and pay the sort of money
to help others adapt but because our
political climate is such that we are
not generous enough rich nations feel
they need to get something in return and
that's what the offset that's where the
offsets come in so it becomes you know
there is an element and theme about
poverty woven in and and and justice and
you know we quoted community members who
say you know the easiest way for me to
send my kids to school to get
electricity and running water is to cut
down trees and have cattle and I can
earn you know hundreds of times more
money by selling some cattle to for beef
then by doing these supposedly
sustainable alternative livelihoods that
you know people in the u.s. want me to
do and just pay me a few dollars so that
is an element of it but I didn't
approach the story thinking about it as
an EJ story it just sort of happened and
then sometimes in other stories you know
sometimes I do stories where it doesn't
fit in and doesn't make it into the
story or makes it in in a sort of
abbreviated form and other times it just
really depends on what the central story
is you're trying to tell so I guess I
feel like for me there are two strands I
have done a couple sort of explicit
environmental justice stories so one I
did I was listening to a podcast about
doesn't matter what but anyway somebody
reference
somebody reference to fact that I'm you
know in parts of California and parts of
LA that black and brown communities are
physically hotter than like white
communities so in summer they get hotter
and I was like well that's weird and so
I did some digging I found there they
mentioned the wreaths they didn't
interview her but they mentioned the
researchers name so I found her and I
called her up and I didn't have a story
and but it was very much like hey I just
think that's interesting what else have
you got and one of the things that she
said was communities that are more
segregated in the United States have
higher overall levels of air pollution
than communities that are more
integrated and I was like huh that's
weird
and the problem but I ran into a problem
so I worked for a newspaper which means
it needs to be new and her research was
a couple of years old by chance and we
were doing the 50th anniversary of
Martin Luther King so they were doing
this big package and I was like King
said something about how segregation was
bad maybe I can tie the two together and
so I talked to these researchers and
then my editor at the time it's really
awesome and he was like um you know I
think based on what you've got so far
you should talk to a king historian so I
found a king historian who's great he
actually talked to me outside the barber
shop and I did a story about sort of how
like King said segregation was not just
bad for black people was bad for white
people and when it comes to pollution
it's true or something like that I don't
remember the exact title it's been a
couple of years because that story a few
months later Al Gore's people reached
out and they said hey we're going to
North Carolina to hang out with Reverend
barber do you want to come and I said
heck yeah and said they were going down
to North Carolina because you guys know
who Reverend barber is for those of you
who don't know he's an african-american
preacher from North Carolina and for the
past I don't know five maybe longer but
he was running this campaign called
moral monday so every Monday like it was
a lot of like getting people to vote and
like getting arrested for sort of social
political reasons around equity and
racial equity and I guess it was last
year he was relaunching Martin Luther
King Junior's poor people
campaign and he was adding eco justice
to the platform that's why Al Gore was
coming to him
so I went down North Carolina I toured a
community that had been impacted by coal
ash I drove out um I had some issues
with my flight so I ended up driving out
after everybody and went out to the
facility just to see the plan and I
interviewed a lot of people who found
that they had a lot of who claim that
they had a lot of helmets from coal ash
and in the news surprise history I
called the energy company that they were
blaming and it's a first time I mostly
science reporter so I talked to
scientists and they like me and I like
them and it's great I mean and being a
little bit glib but um is the first time
I'd ever really had a straight
adversarial interview um so it literally
ended with a PR person screaming at me
and then I hung up the phone very shaken
and then the PR person emailed my boss
so that was a new experience to me could
they figure out who your boss I don't
know I really don't yeah so that was
exciting
um so there are those stories and then
on the other side like recently I did a
story a really short story very image
driven about the bleaching of the coral
reefs in Hawaii and so he's talking to
this researcher and I was like hey you
know most and this is the thing that I
think about a lot with coral reefs which
is that most people who live in the
United States will never see one we
don't except for Florida and like and
our islands in the Caribbean and Hawaii
we don't really have any like in
continental United States that apart
from cold water but that's not what I'm
talking about
and you need some reading for those
anyway this is a problem too much uh but
um so I always whenever possible try to
link it back to people who are impacted
and because coral reefs are like really
critical ecosystems in the areas of the
world tropical coral reefs are really
critical for food in the parts of world
when they show up so he's talking to
this researcher and I was like hey is
there someone in Hawaii that I can talk
to you feel like this matters to in a
way that's more than just science so he
found me this guy who's great who lives
in one of the last traditional Hawaiian
villages on that island and so I
interviewed him and
and I put him in the story and so that's
the other way that I think eco justice
plays out is that we is there's a thread
and sort of eco justice movements which
is community speak for themselves which
often makes your difficult to talk to
eco justice groups because they don't
want to talk to you they're like go
tucked it's persons meaning you're like
great but I want to talk about the work
you're doing no go talk to this person
in the community but what about the work
you're doing and so I think as a
reporter that's that is actually a
really valid thing it's like let people
speak for themselves and it doesn't
always have to be this like this thing
is happening to them they are
participants in what is happening I'm
not saying that they're causing it but
they they are actors in this process and
so it helps to allow them to have that
voice and so that's the other way that I
think is valid and also yeah is yeah
trying to find that voice making sure
that as much as possible if you're
reporting touches on a community that
some in that community is in their story
which isn't always easy especially if
you're used to talking to scientists all
the time yeah yeah no it's really
interesting because it that idea of
including people in the stories as
opposed to right go into so and this is
having to someone changes the whole
dynamic of a story you can make it much
richer I think everyone knows that when
they see it it just says still doesn't
happen very often actually you know it
takes effort and thought and you both
have and this may not be completely true
for you but luxury of resources and and
some time right I mean I'm sure you know
incredibly busy both of you but but so
well two things if you have a question
one I don't want to hoard so please
start there's one thing that I want to
and this is something that I learned the
hard way that's happened to me twice
where I showed up in towns and there is
like a large Native American population
and nobody told me
so like when you're talking to
researchers and you're like is there
anyone else I should talk to you even
non-scientist
issues like kind of be like more
explicit that
like I'm looking are there community
members that I should talk to you
because people forget they get into
their brain and they forget and it's the
same with sourcing I will tell someone I
am is there a woman can I you know like
I've got three dudes can I find a woman
can I find a woman of color can I find
you know a person of color when I did
that King piece I found an
african-american King historian because
I love my experts on the piece were
white it was really important to have
that voice in there I didn't yeah yeah
it's great
the so so I just if you have a question
come to the mic a lot more questions but
please and we'll start having getting a
conversation going but so but just on
this I think that's great a lot of other
journals don't have those resources
right like you guys are very lucky I
think and that and then so two questions
it's not really advice for journalists
but it's it's it's how do you how do you
can you do that quickly and second of
all this is a bigger question but what's
what angles not being covered in climate
that you feel just personally Oh
is there something that we're missing
because there's a lot of climate music
yeah what are we not doing I got was
yeah a drought because it's really hard
to cover because it's super slow-moving
and like dirt looks like what do you
what do you shoot
what do you photograph so it has this
tremendous impact it's really important
but it is very difficult to talk about
and then you end up with like the Cape
Town problem where everyone was like
Cape Town's running out of water and
then Cape Town didn't run out of water
so like there's this real risk of
becoming like the boy who called wolf
and I'm not trying to minimize Cape Town
problems but like so like yeah droughts
in particular it's really difficult yeah
you know I okay this is gonna sound
funny because I don't do this but I
would love to see more solutions climate
journalism in a way that is perhaps more
analytical and talking about here
thing that actually worked and is anyone
actually working to maybe scale it up so
it's not just one neighborhood or one
town I spent a lot of time after
Hurricane Harvey reporting on the
hurricane in Houston I was reporting
actually from my office in New York
which was difficult but one thing that
we kept hearing was oh you know the
greatest success story in relocating an
entire town or an entire community after
flooding is this town in Illinois I
think was called Valmeyer or something
and then I called up the former mayor
about Val Meyer and he's like yeah there
were you know like 300 of us or
something it was some very small number
and I'm looking at the data from the
city of Houston with thousands upon
thousands of requests for buyouts after
the hurricane and just thinking this
wonderful success story which everyone
knows about is completely and not
applicable to the disaster you're seeing
in Houston yet everyone talks about it
like we should follow their example and
I'm thinking who is actually gonna make
this work and so we ended up doing a
story which was not a solution story
about how backed up
Houston's system was and that the the
Houston and Harris County had probably
the most sophisticated system for trying
to get as much money as possible for
buyouts and they were really working
hard they had all this great data an
effort but they were something like 10
years behind on their backlog you know
it was it was tremendous the demand for
people who wanted money to relocate to
most flood-prone places versus the
actual resources they had and you know I
would love to just see more coverage of
solutions that work and how to apply
them in multiple places I want to talk
more about solutions but either question
and we can come back to it so if you
already covered this feel free to
embarrass me publicly I'm cool with that
I was wondering you know in within the
past year there has been a truly
astonishing increase in awareness
surrounding climate change there have
been you know millions of people
protesting and all this kind of stuff
and I was wondering as climate
orders what kind of additional kind of
benefits and challenges does that offer
to your coverage now that there's like
more of kind of a kind of laser focus
than ever before on the issue I think
the benefit is that people are paying
attention and I think institutionally
more people are paying attention but
also I think it's interesting there's a
split so like I think print and new
media gets it and they really are
devoting resources and trying to convey
like the magnitude of climate coverage I
think except for like fights at that
show and HBO they were kind of the one
exception I think it's less true with TV
news and I think people overestimate our
reach not as many people I've got you
know like millions of people a night
watch TV and I don't think any
publication has that equivalent of you
know like I don't think that and I don't
look at my numbers they don't let us but
um I don't think that that many people
read like you know like you know Chris
you know 10 million people tuned into
like cable news shows a night in an hour
I don't think I get 10 million people
clicking on my story do you know
anything and so we think that I think is
the debt like there yeah so we think
there's a that split I think the upside
is the tension I think the downside is
and I notice it's a lot this is kind of
what what was also sort of that's tried
running through that fire story is that
there's a lot of miscommunication I
think that there are a lot of reporters
who haven't covered science and haven't
covered climate change before who are
now becoming climate change reporters
and it's great the more the merrier I'm
not miss marching them but I I did this
is kind of a jerk but like there is a
fire that happened I'm not gonna say
where cuz they'll be able to find their
prettying and it was a natural fire it
was like there was some I mean there
were some issues with the ecosystem
around Ag but basically like it's a
firebase ecosystem nobody lives near it
and made local media because they are
mandatory
operating requirements when smoke hits a
road but it was like it was a nothing
burger fire that like blew up all over
social media because an outlet chose to
report on it and make it a really big
deal
and say it was climate change and it
like just it what and I like was like am
I you know it wasn't another fire
scientists that I really like was on
Twitter was like yelling at people and I
was like cool well I'm not wrong I was
like it's gonna rain tomorrow like like
it's like everything is okay like it is
fine and and that drives me nuts because
I often feel like you only get one shot
and so once people have the wrong idea
in their head it's really hard to change
their minds hi my name is Leanne thank
you so much I learned a lot from this
panel um I had two related questions and
I think there are continuations of the
themes I were talked about today one is
about this resurgence of the political
movement around climate change in
climate justice and I think previously
we thought like science literacy was the
solution to climate denialism
and it's it seems like now like power
literacy is also really important for
general audiences to understand the
political economy of the society that we
live in when we support fossil fuels and
I was just wondering what you guys
thought about that like whether that is
part of your goal as journalists and
this the related question is whether any
aspect of your reporting would change if
the primary audience were activists and
not necessarily people in power who had
the power to change legislation for
example but the people who actually
could use this to organize and be
activists thank you you know I I think
that it I'll answer the second question
first if our primary audience was
activists probably the biggest change
would be not having to explain
everything from scratch and being able
to use more jargon and perhaps and so
that's why I feel I you know I feel like
activists should be reading our
stories and shouldn't have any trouble
understanding it because it's just
stating a lot of what they already know
in plain language and and you know on
the issue of power and balance one thing
that's become very clear and I think to
make stories and makes a really
compelling story is the idea that a lot
of people think the environmental
movement is a monolith and it really
isn't and it's increasingly clear that
there's often a real split between the
big national well-funded environmental
organizations and these smaller
localized environmental justice
organizations that are often run by
communities of color and based locally
and and you know I just did a story on
cap-and-trade in California and those
two groups were on polar opposites of
how they felt about cap-and-trade and so
you know I I covered that the the story
covered the differences in those
opinions and and also you end up finding
I think justice elements that you may
not necessarily think of because you
also have to think about economic
injustice including from people who
don't see themselves as climate
activists and how they can sometimes be
used by either side so one unexpected
story I found when I wrote about cap and
trade was I heard so a cap-and-trade is
this confusing market mechanism where
you give out a bunch of limited permits
to emit co2 and then companies buy them
and they can trade so you know a cut it
allows companies to maybe emit more than
they did the year before but as long as
someone else is emitting less than they
were then everything balances out but
what I had discovered in reporting on
this was there was a lot of flaws in the
cap-and-trade program in California and
I started hearing rumors that there had
been this public regulatory hearing and
that there were these groups of minority
residents who seem to have shown up at
the meeting and perhaps were being
managed by oil and gas somehow to talk
about how making cap-and-trade more
stringent would increase fuel prices and
impact them on a economic level
adversely
and it was a weird rumor and I started
looking at this so I watched the video 5
hour video of the hearing and then I
noticed very clearly this block of black
pastors from Los Angeles they stated
their names in the video so I looked him
up and started calling them I visited
two of them and they basically said oh
yeah we were approached by this
consulting firm who said they would fly
us to Sacramento for the hearing so we
could talk about our economic concerns
with this regulation and then through
lobbying records I figured out that
consulting firm was being paid by this
nonprofit that was mostly funded by oil
and gas and the thing was these pastors
did not know their trip was funded by
oil and gas interests they were not told
that and in fact they had a history of
local advocacy against oil and gas
drilling in their own neighborhoods so
this was a case where they had no idea
what was going on and when I told them
they were very disappointed and very
shocked you know they were very proud of
their local environmental activism they
definitely cared about their communities
and the economic concerns they shared at
the hearing were genuine but it was a
total shock to them that they were you
know they had been funded by interests
that were opposite of what they normally
supported and so I think drilling down
to those kinds of power dynamics and and
revealing them is is it's just a really
important thing for for all stories hi
my name is Jonas and I live in Germany
currently and so one thing that I
observe is that there's quite a big
difference in in climate like awareness
but probably also reporting between say
like Europe and the US and so I wonder
if you had any insights like what might
contribute to days and and also if you
have any particular like challenges
of maybe like reporting of a global
problem like climate change to to a u.s.
audience so I mean like we do still have
I mean one of the biggest differences is
reduced still have a sustained climate
denial s movement and so one of the
things when I bring this up that I
always want to put in context is
actually only about 13% of people in the
United States don't accept the science
of climate change so they're in the
sheer minority and they're some people
when you include people who are like I
don't know what is happening you get to
about 30% so that's 13% denialists and
17% to sort of head-scratching but the
overwhelming majority of americans you
can look this up at Yale climate
communication has really good stats on
this the overwhelming majority of
Americans accept the science I think
there are only two counties in the
United States where it's less than 50%
so that's just like I want to make that
really clear that that's kind of the
backdrop which were operating under as
Lisa's reporting has unveiled the and
what's your name Naomi rescue over at
Harvard has done a lot of great work
sort of highlighting the degree to which
all and gas companies have worked to
perpetuate the disinformation this
disinformation campaign has only
essentially happened in four countries
it's happened in the United States
primarily a little bit has happened in
the UK it's happening in Australia still
and a little bit in Canada instead what
that is meant is that while other
countries had sort of accepted the
science and their news media had
accepted the science a really long time
ago when it's like hominy started when
ten years ago two thousand knowing it
was somewhat radical that they were
reporting on climate change from the
position that it was happening and that
they weren't going to debate the science
anymore
so there's been a really large shift
within media to sort of report from the
perspective that climate change is
happening and we're done with the debate
and that she's sort of how were the
position were operating from and so we
think that's partly what factors into
how that that that conversation is
happening if you're wondering why there
there's such a sustained denial this
movement in the United States and those
four countries part of it is
a strong fossil fuel sector with the
exception of the UK all of these
countries have large private fossil fuel
come sectors so that's a huge part of it
part of it is this idea of freedom and
this idea of the frontier and this idea
that you can't mess with me neoliberal
capitalism basically and English and
that's that there's anything unique
about English it just makes it really
easy to disseminate the information
between those countries so like I'm sure
if we were speaking German then in
Germany might have more of a problem
just and so in in some sense we are
historically really behind in other
countries in terms of popular media sort
of reporting on it as a fact so that's a
huge part of it and then you know we
have governments that don't accept the
science either so like it's not just
that they're you know the 13% if they
were not in positions of power the the
discussion might be very different but
we have a president who is on record is
not accepting the science and we have
many politicians and positions of power
who don't accept the science and so we
are in a position I think as a country
where we can't just sort of say this is
what's happening and act on it we're
still in some ways re redoing that
debate it's not playing out in the media
anymore it is playing out politically
but that does mean when a politician
says something that about climate change
that is not that it's not happening we
do still in many cases have an
obligation depending on the context to
report that and so that means that like
yeah does that make any sense sorry I
like you know it does make sense I mean
it's interesting like let me get another
Hillary had a question in that I'd like
to follow up on that yeah my name is
George McRae for the last ten years been
publishing her free weekly that looks at
what's happening at the colleges and
universities in the community
energy and other things so a lot of it
is about climate change because there's
all these discussions all the time
around here first a piece of information
I started buying a bundle of trees from
heifer international in the ADA right
and after about 10 or 20 years I
realized if I buy a bundle of trees
every year which is about a hundred
trees that are then planted out by
indigenous people through heifer
international that's carbon offset right
so when I fly I buy a bundle of trees
from heifer international and they don't
advertise it as being Carbon office
offset but I think that it is about 20
years ago I asked science fiction
writers about positive futures and they
didn't have any idea there are very few
positive futures if we look at our media
if we look at our fiction we don't have
it everything we're still Mad Max right
it's still about oil and gas but there
are all those kinds of solutions that
are there so how do we overcome this
lack of imagination about solutions even
simple solutions very simple solutions
like the idea of carbon offset through a
tree program which is not related to
climate change or the fact that I carry
a ten dollar solar bike light on my
backpack which can also charge something
which you also be essential power for
the billion or so people who don't have
access to light or a cellphone and it's
10 bucks retail online and we're not
recognizing this stuff so how do you do
this how do you get the solutions
out there how do you talk about carbon
drawdown how do you talk about sell
carbon sequestration that all of these
things are there or tog arose idea of
bio rock which keeps corals alive when
they're bleaching so so so you talking
not just from a consumer standpoint but
in general solutions well it's there
seems to be a lack of imagination in the
culture about any kind of positive
future that is not from the 1950s
there's a book called if someone has a
phone I think it's a great disruption or
the great oh god I can't remember I can
picture the cover it's blue and
relatively recent and I will I don't
know I think is it who's it by no no no
this guy is um like Indian thank you
what's what's the book what the great
derangement thank you the great
derangement who talks a little yeah
derangement who talks a little bit about
like that tension how a lot of the
features are in like serious novels
tends to be relegated to science fiction
and how there aren't a lot of positive
features but I would say like the best
example I can think of is Black Panther
and not just kids of vibranium and and
not just because it was an awesome movie
but also if you look at great Black
Panther there is an urban core and
there's a countryside but it doesn't
actually have a suburbs and the city
center doesn't have paved roads so
they're said like those visions are out
there they're just you have to look a
little bit more to see them and you have
to be really nerdy to notice details
that like there are no paved roads in
Wakanda you know the advice so the
sidewalks I should say are unpaved
but it's an issue that we talked a
little bit earlier about about have it
everyone here know about so this was a
solution Network have you guys heard of
it so so it's a cool effort to write
about solutions to problems with the
rigor that you apply to investigative
journalism and it's it's it's it's a
good idea it's very hard to do oh and I
just saw it lovely so just like just
touch on solutions like is it is it
important for journalists to visit your
job to give everyday solutions to people
as well as sort of broader solutions to
explain them and and having fed how do
you how do you balance that against the
the need to report on the news and this
yeah yeah you know I I think we do often
times that ProPublica will spend an
entire year writing about the problem in
increasingly depressing chapters of a
story and then maybe at the end of the
year a few stories about solutions you
know here is one state that is doing
this thing well whereas the state we
wrote about is failing at it or here's
one company that is making some inroads
here's one happy story about this thing
we don't do it very often because that
is not the core of why we're here but we
have sometimes created depending on the
project kind of users guides to help
people advocate for themselves
so we have these great healthcare
journalists who've created guides on
when you're at the hospital here's what
you do to make sure you don't get
charged and get ridiculous surprise
bills you know here are the steps of
what to do a couple years ago one of my
colleagues did a great series on the
problem of maternal mortality in the
u.s. how women giving birth in the US
are at much higher risk of injury and
deaths than almost any other developed
nation and at the end of that we publish
an entire user's guide on you know if
you are the spouse or family member of
the person giving birth in the hospital
here are the steps you take to make sure
all of your concerns are addressed to
make sure the risks are you know taken
care of as much as possible here's what
you do to reduce the risk that your
loved one might you know
suffer or die or get injured in the
process so I think those kinds of
practical guides are very important I
have not found a way to do one of those
in my reporting so far but I think a lot
of daily newspapers and and and other
publications do a better job on on and
do a lot more reporting on consumer
oriented you know advice and there's
certainly a lot of stories out there
saying okay what can you as a single
person do for climate change and
oftentimes it comes down to voting
you know vote and get involved in local
politics because that's where you as an
individual often can make the the
biggest difference I also think like I
think with the globe just did that
awesome article about like how bad
traffic is in Boston and the thing is
it's like everybody like transportation
planners know that building roads
doesn't reduce congestion adapt it just
adds to it right but there are all of
these things that like the solutions are
like known it's just that the political
will isn't there to do them so that's
the other tension right like we need
mass investment in mass transit that's
the only thing that actually reduces
traffic but like we don't do that in
this country so like yeah so like that's
the other attention which solution
stories is that that sometimes the
solutions are just so obvious and
everybody knows what they are but like
there's no movement on them often for
value and socio-political reasons as
opposed to for technical reasons high
thinks I'm Jenny I'm with living on
earth or a public radio program that
Lisa song interned at I think a few
years ago and we have a podcast as well
so please subscribe but one thing I'm
thinking about a lot right now is the
upcoming UNF Triple C conference of the
parties climate meetings that are going
to happen in Madrid after being moved
from Chile from Santiago and there's
gonna be a lot of discussion there of
course the u.s. is stepping back from
its role in this global movement to have
some kind of agreement about what are we
doing about climate change and so I'm
wondering to what extent you feel that
kind of conversationally covering these
meetings is important to your audiences
and something that you should you know
be informing them about because I feel
like it's not cut that covered in the
media it's just not that sexy of a thing
to report on and also how do you try to
go about that and sort of like draw out
the most salient important parts of that
kind of like really high level diplomacy
for your general audiences laughing
because it inside climate news it's
always a great discussion should you go
do that anyway I mean I'm gonna be
honest and say it's really boring
you go and cover those conferences um
it's a lot of bureaucracy a lot of
jargon way more acronyms than anyone
should ever have to deal with and you
know unfortunately oftentimes there's
not a lot of movement you know I I
covered some of the events I went to
some of the events in September during
climate week in New York because I was
right there and I came away with it
thinking nobody's really talking about
reducing the use of fossil fuels which
is the bottom-line thing you need
everyone is talking about there was so
much more discussion of carbon trading
and offsets but nobody used the word
offsets
they used all these other euphemisms and
I complained enough about it that my
editor just said why don't you just
write that story so I ended up writing a
story that was not focused on the
step-by-step events of the meeting but
on this one slice about a topic that I'd
spent months researching and could write
about you know quickly and with
authority and that's sort of how we tend
to cover those events we don't cover we
know there's there were hundreds and
hundreds of reporters covering these
meetings actually during climate week it
was very encouraging to see the giant
media tent filled to capacity so there's
plenty of daily coverage of what's
actually happening and we try to cover
these kinds of things only one it falls
into something that we can offer that's
unique and new and and I think I'm not
sure why it seems like the the reporting
on these kinds of UN meetings ten
to be more robust in a lot of European
publications then then us ones I don't
cover the cop advocate where he
dismissed of our foreign international
stuff and she has spent a lot of time
time at the UN and so she covers cop
I've never been to a cop and during
climate week I only went to the side
meetings yeah it's right incremental and
I don't know who was first okay sorry
hi so I think many of us here at MIT
were engineers and scientists so I was
wondering if you have any advice for us
on how to best communicate our work to
you journalists I like puns no I I mean
it often helps like if you're doing
something super technical it really does
help to have a really good analogy and
that you can give out ideally if you're
talking to a lot of journalists have
more than one so it doesn't look like
we're all ripping each other off and
then also like why does it matter is
awesome so really important so um and
yeah and sometimes if you have a really
compelling story so I did um this isn't
at the time this is when I was at pops I
there's an annual award I think it's
like the Golden Goose award or something
I don't remember but it award rewards
sort of basic science that have yielded
unusual benefits and so that year it was
like a fraud I like a guy who studied um
like an insect or something I founded an
evil glue I don't remember the third guy
sorry and this woman who essentially she
was the one who helped identify key
trade in frogs and I was kind of like
man do I really have to do this do I
really have to write an article about an
award it doesn't get your blood racing
but I called her so I wanted to call one
of them so I called her just by chance
and she did this amazing story
essentially of like studying science in
college and getting her master's degree
and then she's an older woman and then
quitting I'm deciding to be stay-at-home
mom for a really long time and then
somebody called her because at that
point she was still the foremost expert
in this in kitchens nobody cared about
it and somebody came in
to do a little bit where they had and
like a grant and somebody convinced her
to come out of like retirement so she'd
been out of the lab for like twenty
years
and do something in their lab for them
and she got the bug again went back to
get her PhD I'm like in her 40s I think
and couldn't get funding to run our own
labs he was literally carving out weird
lab space out of somebody else's lab and
when they first were sort of identifying
what key trade was he like we're like oh
who they found somebody else and they
contacted them they're like you know
what this isn't here I'm like I don't
know but you should talk to this woman
and they did and so it was like this
really great story of this woman's life
and it wouldn't have that like it would
have been a much less rich article if
she hadn't opened up to me so sometimes
if your story is to like why you've got
to do the thing that you're doing is
really lovely like don't be afraid of
sharing that I think the analogy people
give is if you're studying something
technical and you want a reporter to
understand pretend you're talking to
your drunk uncle you know like someone
who's who cares and really wants to
understand but you know needs things
broken down simply so that can help and
then if you're really interested in
being a frequent source to reporters
there are actually trainings that are
available to help scientists better
communicate to the media and I think
those trainings can also teach you some
of the rules of the road for journalism
so you're not shocked by you know how
you may be described by the journalists
and and you kind of know that the
practices and what's accepted or not in
journalism I'm just gonna jump in
because I was a science reporter for
many years of the globe in and I used to
teach MBL science communication to
postdocs for a while and and it's like
building a relationship with the
journalists early on is really important
and I'm also gonna make a plug for my so
I don't feel like it's a plug for
anything commercial but it's I think
it's important the conversation which is
a non-profit independent news site but
what we do see is something different we
work with academics postdocs can write
for us master students if they have a
professor and and they we help translate
their research under their byline into
public interest journals and that then
goes out on the AP wire goes to the
Washington Post
other places so like I'm just saying
that's an option because every
journalist I know goes on the
conversation every day and then calls up
all the people we help right and get
them on their radio interviews and the
you know what I mean so I just I'm
throwing it out there because it's a
it's a good resource to get in front of
journalists in a different way but that
helpful okay go ahead thank you my name
is Betty and I think what I have to ask
comment on is related to what George
said and he gave me courage to stand up
you were talking about how it's kind of
a downer so the problem of getting
people to read about this and I'm
thinking of some publications I mean one
question is whether you know the
magazine yes which is a quarterly I had
a subscription to it for a year but I
actually talked the Cambridge Public
Library into subscribing to it and as
you know then if you're familiar with it
I mean these are positive stories
obviously and a lot of these things are
grassroots I mean it's what people are
doing at the local level so I think it
does kind of give people hope and and
exposes them to possible if not solution
solutions sounds like too big too grand
but you know things that people can do
at least and and then there are these
publications like this is the Nature
Conservancy the publication that they
put out which is also quarterly and and
obviously the Sierra Club does the same
kind of thing but anyway these are all
kind of positive stories maybe part of
their purpose is to get people to join
and to contribute to their organizations
but they're not made up so I just wonder
what you how you feel about these kind
of publications like yes and the Nature
Conservancy and Sierra Club which you
really do have a lot of good stories
yeah I think considered more advocacy
based because there's they're spurring
public action right yeah I mean I read a
lot of climate stories you know I it's I
usually start by more my mornings by
getting the
climate Nexus newsletter find it think
of that's the right name but they do a
roundup every day of climate related
stories from the day before and I'll
read and skim a lot I'm on Twitter a lot
and I try to keep some general
understanding of all kinds of climate
everything happening in the climate
space even though I only write about
small sections of it and you know when
good solution stories come out I read
them it just depends on but but like I
said it tends not to be the focus of the
kind of work that I do routinely sort of
similar you know I read through here I
read Audubon but those are just
different outlets and also I do a lot of
like study reporting and so um there
aren't that many positive climate change
studies I don't know why you know why hi
I'm Connor so when you're talking about
the phrase climate crisis earlier and
just you know the phrases that get used
over and over again remind me of this
thing from last year during the
California fires where Trump started
using this phrase I think forest
management and that the problem is
forest management I was like huh is he
talking about controlled burns that's
really interesting but then someone
clued me into no actually this is like a
Trojan horse for logging and I was like
oh well that that completely could have
gotten me unless someone had pointed
this out so anyway I guess I was just
curious is this something that you feel
like comes up a lot these sort of Trojan
horse phrases I guess and are there any
in particular that you try to avoid or
you're thinking about right now I try
not to repeat political talking points
which is hard because political talking
points become like language so I'm not
saying I'm like perfect at it but I do
try to avoid them it's been a lot of
time in thesaurus.com coming up with
other phrases I can't think of another
one offhand
I mean this one's kind of obvious but I
really try avoiding forest fire because
most for it most like especially like
the California fire fires a lot of them
are not in forests or in chopper out
there and grasslands or brush lands so
that's just like one that I try and then
you end up like with like a lot of like
wonky and wild land management because
you're not you're trying not to say for
us to things like that yeah yeah I don't
know I can't think of any kind of
political off the top of my head it's
more that we try to just avoid the
jargony thing altogether right so in
cap-and-trade the actual permits you buy
are called allowances and I was thinking
nobody nobody cares what an allowance is
nobody needs to understand that word so
we just use the word permit and so even
if there was some political you know
slant to the word allowance even if
there was we just don't have to worry
about it because we're using a normal
common everyday word and so I think the
thing we watch out for most is if a word
is being used in the context of some
jargon specific policy thing and it
perhaps means something different from
the way normal people understand it then
we find a way to take care of that
usually by using a synonym somehow so I
thought everyone I I'm not very
successful because editors
then I try not to use the phrase natural
disaster I try I kind of agree with
natural hazard or disaster experts which
is a disaster is a natural hazard that
means the human population so if you
have a tornado and it doesn't any I
don't know it goes through nowhere or
like no community then it's not a
disaster Chester tornado and I think the
problem with a natural disaster is it
ignores the fact that oftentimes your
systems and processes that put people
into harm's way so it makes it seem
inevitable and that's not true hi first
of all thank you so much for this
amazing conversation I'm if our
environmental journalist from Brazil
actually and
yeah so first I have only a brief
comment to add into something you
mentioned Kendra I I think the
disinformation campaign when far beyond
the support countries that you mentioned
I I agree that's exactly where like the
feat was a stronger but whatever happens
here has several severe implications for
developed for the development countries
especially with big markets like Brazil
so and and an important thing to say I'm
sorry for talking so much but an
important thing to say is that there's
there's there's a curve there's what is
happening in Brazil right now is the
disinformation campaign produced by the
government it is very important to
whatever story you go to cover that to
be aware of that especially with the
fires the more the current index was
releasing the deforestation indexed
index was released Monday and it is
proven that the fires in August are
directly connected with the increase in
the four stations so we are not seeing a
growth that is connected with past years
we are actually going back to ten years
backwards you know it's it's it's it's a
different situation it's much worse but
sonar is a technical person and he's and
his line he's saying that fires are
cultural the fires are natural in the
rainforest which is not true the
rainforest is not an ecosystem for it I
actually talked about that in the piece
not about them being natural bit about
how it's just a really good piece mate
thank you about like the fact that
indigenous people when they set fires
they set them differently and they
allowed the land to regrow and so yeah I
agree with you I was not at all implying
that what was happening in the Amazon is
like natural yeah no I'm sorry to
connect the two topics but I'm actually
a green
I don't mean to lecture but I'm more
like taking advantage of this
opportunity to state what is happening
in Brazil because it's so important
whatever happens in the rainforest for
the nice necklace next two decades
decades is going to have implications
for the whole world both scenario is the
biggest threat for climate change right
now so all that said I'm sorry about
that I just when I asked you don't you
think as an as a journalist I think we
are spending too much energy and time
discussing vocabulary like it is a huge
crisis and we are like discussing about
making it more making it nicer for
readers you know it's a crisis we have
to say what is happening it's a huge
problem so don't you think that instead
of speaking about that we should be
speaking about how to make it more
personal how to make our coverage more
personal to people I think I think like
I guess that's what I was saying earlier
which is when I can't when I because I
can't say climate crisis because I can't
use it I can't say inflammatory language
as a knee jerk I have to talk to people
I have to link it back to what's
happening to people and what's happening
to communities and let that tell the
story as opposed to saying like we're
all gonna die which we are but you know
it's really interesting I mean this idea
of climate crisis sort of denotes you're
saying it is a crisis but well it's a
problem some people it just true may not
see it as a crisis right their
perception of risk is very different
potentially right they see as hunger for
children in a you know in X is the
crisis so I think I just was curious how
you think about that right you call
something crisis you it's very important
but you called that the crisis or
something else and do you go down a
slippery slope when you start doing that
I don't know I think the thing that I'm
most concerned about is that some people
think that they can
of the problem that like Oh it'll be a
problem in Bangladesh or um we got an
email one time from someone in
California he was like I don't live on
the coast so why should I care about
climate change and so that has you know
I'm you know a judge for a while that I
had a new sea level rise no coral reefs
rule I'm in a dough it's not like a hard
and fast rule but I do think that
because you're so visual and because
it's just so easy to you know you can go
to Louisiana and you can see that you
know the areas that are flooding and can
go to Virginia and you can see the areas
that are flooding it becomes an easy
crutch to use that as a narrative and
the risk and that was why I brought up
droughts earlier it's a risk that we run
into is that people who are going to be
horrific affected in really severe ways
don't know it because unfortunately it's
like not visual enough I did I joke that
I'm on the animal beat but I did this
story about how bears black bears won't
hibernate as it gets warmer and yeah and
so the coach of it you're like well why
do I care I'm not a bear but like the
problem the problem is is that if they
don't hibernate like bears black bears
are like just smart enough to be a
problem I'm so if they don't hibernate
they do things like they break into
people's homes and then you have to put
them down or you hit them with your car
and you die this has happened so like
like it's the longer they're weak the
more these kinds of incidents happen and
so like in the story I'm just because of
a weird settlement in Nevada
there was this whole list of all of
these like bear complaints that people
put in and say put the complaints in the
story and it was like some of it was
like you know I went outside and there
was a bear swimming in my pool like that
is very good go ahead first of all thank
you so much and I actually also worked
with Jenny yet living on earth so so
something I think a lot about when I
think of journalism
and also very relevant environmental
journalism is bias and it's so hard to
balance you know between as we were
talking before advocacy versus being
objective and also the different
solutions and like how do you not like
focus on one versus another and as
journalists I'd love to hear your
perspective on how you balance these
different biases I mean both the New
York Times and Pro Publica
have reputations for a certain bias in
the political spectrum is that something
that you ever consider when you're
pitching a story or how like what is
that process in terms of recognizing
that you're having not just multiple
sides of the story but the right sides
and putting significant weight to
everything that might matter and
ignoring the noise I mean I first I
don't think it's bias to say that the
planet should be livable like I'm you
know if people say because you write
about climate change and you want you
know the planet to be inhabitable by
humans for a sustainable period of time
then that counts as biased and I think
that's a problem so and also you know we
we go after the facts so we are starting
from the baseline that climate change is
real it's a serious problem and you know
we're not you know and then that is like
the baseline assumption when you read
any of our climate stories I think the
other thing that we take very seriously
as we have a no surprises rule so before
publication particularly with our longer
investigations we contact every person
quoted and mentioned in the story and we
do a fact check right it doesn't mean if
they say something doesn't mean we let
them control what we say but we make it
very clear to them we're gonna tell you
how we quote you in the story or how we
talk about you in this story and we're
gonna check the facts and if you can
show us objectively that we've gotten
something wrong we'll fix it but if you
know maybe you said something in a
little more emphatic way than perhaps
you would like it but it's still
factually correct
we may not change it so I think dealing
with that helps make people understand
how seriously we take it and and our
approach and you know I've talked to
sources who may not be happy but they
appreciate that we do that fact-checking
you know very rigorously and I've even
done things like I've had experiences
where I've talked to the authors of a
report and say this is how we summarize
your report in one sentence and they
might say something like well I don't
think that's accurate and then I'm
saying here is the exact line in your
study that says what we're saying so
I've had instances where I end up
without checking them and make them
realize that's actually what their
report is saying because it's theirs
it's known as that the media has a
liberal bias so I don't think it I'm
just curious how you dealing um so I
think that media in general there's a
really big discussion right now around
what is bias and what is neutrality and
often neutrality has been through a
white male affluent ease and there's
been a lot of pushback against that
lately I think because that they aren't
the world and but that is a fact
like and there's a really good paper
that's called the weirdest people in the
world and the weird I can't never
remember what it's not her it's like
Western educated about the bias inherent
in a lot of psychological studies
because they're all on Western are like
you know us mainly um so I don't operate
from the I operate from the perspective
that we're all biased and that I you
know I've even tweeted out but I ever
Pro Earth bias I'm definitely bias in
that regard but so that doesn't I feel
like we're that bias where anyone's bias
comes up is in the stories that you
choose to report on more than how you
execute those stories and so I'm
constantly consumed with the stories
that I'm not telling and the stories
that I want to tell and figuring out how
I can tell those stories it's like what
kind of consumes my time as opposed to
whether or not someone is going to email
me or call me a [ __ ] which it's happened
because they're gonna do that anyway and
I don't really care if the facts are
right um yeah I'm just gonna add that I
think you should you know they're
probably sometime again on the radio
sorry
I think sometimes there may be a
different because climate change has
become so politicized there sometimes a
different standard applied to what
people perceive as bias and alignment
journalist so if you're an education
journalist it's pretty much taken for
granted that it your position is
children should have a good education in
their school and have adequate resources
and like not be abused by the staff or
the teachers and having that as your
baseline assumption does not make you
biased you know in the same way that
business reporters have the baseline
assumption when the economy grows it's
good no business reporter probably is
going around saying let's have a
recession we need a recession like if we
can accept those basic truths as not
being biased in those other beats then I
don't see why like Kendra said being Pro
Earth should be considered a bias and I
mean I've tweeted this before so I'm and
someone's probably coded me on this but
like what she was saying about business
reporter one of my perpetual
frustrations is when you're watching the
debate and there's some TV reporter
interviewing a candidate that is talking
about their economic platform the person
interviewing them is a millionaire that
is a bias they do not have the same
economic interests as the vast majority
of Americans but that is somehow fine
that is unremarked upon we've we've
accepted that as normal but if you're a
woman or if you're a person of color
there's implicit in a lot of journalism
that's viewpoint that you're biased
somehow that is that is bias so I think
yeah so that's why I hate that question
and why I think bias is I think we're
all biased to be a question just want to
get to everything everyone so go ahead
sorry I didn't eat that question but
[Laughter]
I think yeah I had one question already
so feel free to just skip it or give a
very short answer I would be interested
in like your your mode of of having
impact as journalists like I you said
before that you you like your your work
to be read by like politicians or people
who have power to change something and I
guess you also have some sort of power
to like move people on a spectrum from I
want you to panic to like feel good
solution stories maybe or I guess you
have a lot of different ways to have
impact on people and I would be
interested in like how did how does work
even as they approach stories are they
thinking about what kind of impact they
want other people or the the end result
I'm thinking about the end result like
like you said you were Pro Earth right
and and so probably there's some hope
that through your work your journalism
you might move the needle a bit and and
I was wondering like through - what
means - what does this happen sure I
mean I think it's it can be particularly
difficult to move the needle on climate
change because it's become so
politicized and you know it's it's so
difficult to talk about for for many
people and and I think that um
you know I think perhaps what has
actually happened in the past couple of
years is does give me optimism because
the public's urgency about climate
change has gone up exponentially the
public's anger in some ways in in
recognizing that there's no getting away
from reducing fossil fuel usage and
reducing the actual production of fossil
fuels and that this one message that
activists have spent years trying to get
out the idea of leave it in the ground
there's a lot of fossil fuel reserves we
simply cannot afford to dig up and burn
if we are to keep the planet at a
reasonable temperature that has gotten
into the public conscious you know in a
much bigger way and there is a lot more
attempts to hold fossil fuel companies
accountable through severe
it's lawsuits you know ExxonMobil was
just on trial in New York a few weeks
ago and and through the idea that you
know yes there are things we can do as
individuals to help with the climate
solution but ultimately we we are gonna
need huge systemic changes to solve this
in a reasonable way and doing that we're
not gonna get there just by recycling
your lunch
tofu container or something I think for
me I think a lot about the nation of
informed consent and so we are making a
decision as a society as a planet about
the future of this planet but many of us
are doing it very passively and so for
me it's making sure that whatever
direction we going so let's say we go
through to the worst-case scenario that
people are almost making that we're
making a clear-eyed decision that we we
do you want to jump off this cliff as
opposed to it being something that is
happening to us this picks up on a
little bit of what you were just saying
Lee so what are your impressions about
the fossil fuel industry companies and
the automobile industry and so on
toward this problem I'm sure you
encounter them in your reporting and I'd
be curious to hear what what your
impressions are about where they stand
regarding the issue solutions their
responsibilities so on I mean I think in
the past few years there's been a lot of
both reporting and academic research
that has unearthed how long fossil fuel
and utilities and some car companies
have understood that their main products
are contributing to climate change you
know I was part of the team at inside
climate that wrote those stories about
exons history in really good climate
research and how that was very different
from their later move into funding
disinformation campaigns there's been a
lot of academics digging through
archives finding oil company involvement
in climate related research as far back
as the 6th
and so I think this is you know the the
history of what they knew is becoming
clearer and clearer and now there is I
think increasing accountability from the
public to try to get them to change
their core business model and there was
a really good story actually in The New
York Times by by your colleague about I
think she attended some conference where
fossil fuel executives were saying look
at how much money we spent the past year
on various clean energy initiatives and
and the reporter did the calculations
who did the math and said but even the
most you know even the companies
spending the most that was only a few
percent of their overall overall
spending so you can see that despite the
big numbers being thrown around it's
it's a marginal priority for them
compared to their continued work in
getting new oil and gas and so I think
that those kinds of the the truth about
what what they're doing and the extent
of their investment in various fossil
fuel alternatives is getting more and
more attention and people are paying
more attention and and trying to hold
them accountable in increasing ways
filmer kind of inside climate news first
just want to say it's great to see three
inside climate newest alums but a
question for both of you
we sent Kendra about kind of work and
process we say you have an incredible
luxury of having months or a year or
possibly more to work on a single story
and I'm wondering how do you keep
momentum how do you keep yourself going
with such a long deadline oh and then
asking both of them let you both respond
then Kendra for you as you're writing so
many stories how do you carve out time
to do bigger stories more enterprise
stories
do you or to get that in how do you find
the time to do that I guess for momentum
it's you know I talk a lot with my
editor it helps to have someone to talk
to whether it's a colleague you're
working with or an editor to just keep
checking in and make sure am I going in
the right direction am i finding enough
new things that this is starting to feel
like a real story checking in to make
sure I'm not diving into some weird
rabbit hole that's useless and going to
waste my time because the whole point of
having a lot of time to work on a
stories you want to make sure you're
spending your time efficiently so that
the final product is worth it and so you
know do a lot of check-ins I try to
write summaries for myself sometimes
during the reporting process or memos
and outlines and just anything I can to
make sure the shape of the story is
turning out in a way that seems worth it
and I oftentimes you know because it's
an investigation you're driven by the
idea that this is really important info
and the public needs to know it and that
in itself is often just a great
motivator for me I I kind of feel like
I'm a gas monkey so I would love to say
that like oh I carve out an hour every
day to work on my longer form things I
do not so basically wait for there to
stop being fires or a lull and like
scientific research and then I like hide
and squirrel away on the thing that I've
been working on for a longer period of
time and then something inevitably pops
up and I have to shove it in a dirt
corner and then a week or two goes by
and I go back to it or longer I am doing
story now that I started in January and
I'm like I'm finally writing it and I
knew I interviewed someone and I could
not find the file because I also
switched computers halfway because it
and phones because of course you do and
I was like I know I interviewed him and
I was like maybe maybe I talked to him
on the phone and because my computer is
enough of a mess
I didn't delete the folder that contains
all of the files from my old phone
even though it's a duplicate file and it
was in there and I found it because um I
found the email where we agreed to have
the interview and then I sorted the
audio files by date so yeah I don't I
don't have a really good answer what you
do it you get it done yeah you know
we're supposed to be done at 8:00 and it
is like exactly 8:00 so I Tony very end
of applause for
[Applause]